I'd like to tell you a story about
trouble I got and if I could Conan I
know what I was hoping you would oh
great thank you so I was obsessed with
Radiohead at the time I was my favorite
band they still kind of are I worshipped
Thom Yorke I'm 17 years old they're
coming to DC and they're playing this
club the 930 Club and I'm so excited but
the only shows I've been going to her
punk shows where I roll on the ground
and scream and it's nightmare and
Radiohead's not that kind of a band it's
not right
I know that now thank you and I go with
my buddy Ryan and we're wearing our
spiky hair and just ready to be horrible
people and Radiohead's planned their
fantastic
Tom York is singing I'm loving it and I
have this great idea that I should crowd
surf here it's like not a hard big loud
song I just think this is gonna be this
will work somehow and yeah I'm like Ryan
boost me up he's like yeah man and he
launches me up over these peoples heads
towards the stage no one's ready for
this no one's been crowd surfing the
whole time I Mack these people in the
back of the head I take out like four
people onto the ground right a sprawling
mess I'm standing up on them I'm
stepping on people people are upset yeah
surely I'm upset hearing about you're
right and you're not the only one
because I realize as I'm standing up
that the music is completely styled and
thom yorke my hero is staring at me and
he goes [ __ ] no more crowd surfing
and I was like mortified obviously
people crafts if I [ __ ] I'm playing
by the rules of Yahoo's I go yes you
didn't know I saw I go sneaking off to
the side I stand against the wall I want
to leave he's like finish the song
finish the song he finishes the song and
when he's done he like looks around and
he finds me hiding he's like
unbelievable dick
[Laughter]
you're branded that for life Syracuse Oh
like that he runs thom yorke sounds like
he runs a pirate ship sure he was just
having a rough night
you